welcome back to 820 special relativity
so if there is a time dilation effect
through gravitational fields
then there is also a redshift to the
gravitational fields
so a consequence of time dilation is a
change in the light frequency and i ask
you to estimate the magnitude of this
effect
and the example you want to use is the
one shown here so you have a tower which
is
not randomly but 22 and a half meters
tall
and
a light beam is sent down
obviously the tower is built on this
planet and this there's gravity is
acting
um so this this is basically an
accelerating
um reference frame
the length of the tower is again 22
meters and i would like you to just get
a feeling
how big can this effect be the effect of
redshift here
so please try to work this out
the way to to think about this is first
to say okay now the light you know the
delta t for the light to travel
um is l divided by c the speed of light
is c the length is l
the change in velocity
is
g
acceleration times l divided by c
so the doppler shift then is the
frequency the new frequency divided by
the initial frequency
and that can be approximated by one plus
delta v over c so we find that it's one
plus
g times l over c square
now the speed of light is pretty fast
um three times ten to the um to the nine
meter per second
and this distance is only 22 and a half
meters so we find that this is a tiny
tiny tiny effect but nevertheless
um
[Music]
experimentalists at harvard tested this
effect the pound replica and snyder in
the 1950s and 50s and 60s were able to
show this this very tiny um effect
you want to know more about this you can
for example look up a small description
in wikipedia here
but there's
some quite some literature on those
experimental tests
you